all right Cayman and Skye came in and
sky where you guys from originally North
Carolina Greensboro North Carolina tell
me about your childhoods Scotty what was
your family like growing up
um I was raised by my mom pretty much my
dad was incarcerated
and
I mean it was pretty sheltered at normal
I guess
my childhood anyhow
Cayman how about you
um well like my my dad and mom both went
to prison so I was adopted out but
my childhood was great honestly you know
my adopted parents neither one of them
did drugs or smoked you know went to
church every week
uh
you know we wouldn't
rich but we you know we weren't like
broke either you know
it's just like a normal childhood I
guess
nothing terrible
no it was it was good
how far you guys go in school
I went
I was good all through elementary and
middle school but I dropped out in high
school
and
I went back a couple times but I still
haven't finished so I guess I'm still
continuing the education
I dropped out the 11th grade
and then I got my GED uh the first time
I went to prison yeah so I got my GED at
least
whatever you going to prison for
I went to prison for organized retail
theft hmm
uh basically just like a bunch of
larcenies a lot of Larson's you guys
feel like having parents that were in
prison kind of
LED you down to the path that was
similar
I've heard that you know like okay so
like my dad is pretty like my biological
dad my mom who had me with was a
stripper
and uh so it's true yeah I had never met
my biological dad until I was 16 and uh
I show up on his doorstep
and my first baby mom was a stripper you
know and like me and him we look the
same we listen to the same like we had
never met but it's just like it's it's
wild how we had never even known each
other but we were like exactly it's just
weird you know interesting
and and Skye you're
you're your dad was in in prison yeah my
dad was in prison for a majority of my
childhood he
'd been there he's there he's my dad but
we don't have the connection like I had
with my mom my mom passed away in 2014.
I mean ever since then I've kind of grew
up honestly I was a baby until I was
what 23 when she passed
so yeah
drugs have been a part of your lives
unfortunately since when
did I start
um depending on the drug like I started
smoking weed when I was 15 cigarettes
knock off both 15
and
um everything else came
like in my
eight I was like 18 or 19 when I first
did anything else like cocaine or
benzos 18 19
I don't really do that many jokes he's
he's the intaker on drugs
yeah I pretty much started everything at
16 like I started shooting heroin at 16.
and I've been opioid dependent ever
since what part of North Carolina are
you guys from Western or Eastern
Greensboro Eastern
and what led you out here to Los Angeles
we
um joined uh well we got
put in a recovery program and uh we were
doing fine until like the recovery
program had different it was too many
different levels at the same
place of severity so there was there
would be two two days clean versus two
months clean versus two years clean you
know that that to him it was hard but
for me coming coming off ice I I didn't
have an issue with it because I don't go
through or suffer the withdrawals like
he does
yeah see this was like the first time in
my life that I ever chose to get clean
on my own every other time I got sober
it was you know I was made to I got sent
to prison
but this time I chose on my own for me
and her to come out here and get cleaned
I made it 14 days
which I know is not very long but to me
it's like you know I've never done in
the last 10 years I've never gone 14
days I hope yes that's hard
you know and he practically done it
without any kind of medication to help
but I was like she said you know I'm in
there I'm two weeks clean and then they
got people coming in office like just
getting there and you know they still
got drugs and there's nodding out and
you know
you know I'm human I you know I made a
mistake and I relapsed but
what is your drug now fentanyl yes
this guy what are you using I smoke ice
crystal meth oh
that's how I do how long you guys been
together
a year
what are your goals what do you want to
see happen in the next few years for you
uh
the next few years I want to see us both
in a better place
so we're in the worst place ever here
yeah this definitely is not where I
would picture it
being better at we always said we would
make each other better so that's what I
want to do
how old are you guys I'm 32. I'm 26.
and you're staying wearing a tent oh no
we are staying in between friends pretty
much it was crashing it wherever you can
pretty much
I refuse to sleep in the tent on a skid
row I'm sorry yeah keep it that way
yes how do you guys make money
well right now the gr that you know gr
yeah right now you know you got that
recruiting job and I yeah I just started
you know I go out and uh uh find people
who are willing to
take a take a test like a HIV test a
blood test and uh it don't matter what
it what the result is you know you take
the test and they they'll give you a 20
gift card to like Target
and I will get a card for referring them
you know so I just started that
yesterday
but other than that you know it's pretty
much been the gr you know we ain't
really it's kind of we've been
struggling here like it's hard to have a
job when you're on fentanyl right yeah
well we were in the program at first and
the program you know they don't want you
to have a job you know they want you to
focus on your sobriety at first make
sure that you're strong enough to
go out and be or you know work and have
money and be around it
so that was kind of what was holding me
back that then but uh you know now
I'm ready to work and I need work I'm
looking for work so you know anything
helps do you think having
the parents the role models that you had
growing up kind of
almost
limited your your options like in terms
of what you what you're open to seeing
happen for in your life
I mean
I'm not from the outside looking in like
like between him and his dad I see like
his dad taught him a trade he learned he
learned to skill trade from his dad
which was like carpentry and like what
else framing
it's the same things whatever I don't
know about it yeah I I can I I do like
any any type of Home Remodeling and um
like I can build decks like floors
anything like that anything other than
electrical and plumbing I can pretty
much do you know I'm not like him you
know he's been doing it 30 years but you
know he's taught me he's taught me good
and like I can pretty much like if I had
money and I had my tool back my tool
belt and my my tools I can pretty much
walk on any construction site and get a
job you know with what I know
but uh
you know I don't have anything out here
right now so I'm just trying to we're
trying to get started you know
[Music]
many times
the drugs out this out in LA are way
stronger than the ones back in North
Carolina
is that right yeah it is it's stronger
and there's more of it and and
the last time he all did was maybe about
a week and a half ago right
but he didn't know he doesn't count that
because he wasn't there
course but I counted it because I was
there
hey so when you OD it happened so fast
you know what I mean we were literally
in a restaurant when you come to you're
disoriented yeah I had no idea what was
going on but we were in a restaurant and
I told her I was like we ordered I said
all right I'm gonna meet you outside
as I started looking for him I walked I
was going outside and I there was a
table right at the door and uh I sat
down for a second all I remember was
putting my head down
and I woke up
people yelling at me she's yelling and
I'm like what's going on you know
I I OD'd and went out you know
you know so I definitely recommend if
you know anyone doing drugs or even if
you don't like just period I think
everyone should should carry uh Narcan
just because you never know when you can
save someone you know yeah
not be in the restaurant ordering food
and somebody at the table next to you
you know it's an easy way to save a life
right yeah do you have kids either you
guys I have kids of my own he has kids
of his own right where are the kids
my kids are back home and um I'm
actually they're actually their
grandmother has custody of them
and I'm working on getting a home for
them here
yeah
you got kids too yeah I had a daughter
and a son a nine-year-old son and a
two-year-old daughter
my son is with my adopted parents who
raised me and my daughter is with the
mother right now
if you guys had your life to live all
over again what would you have done
differently
a lot
I like to say if I could go back and
know what I know now I'd do things a
whole lot different
you know I say that
and you know I definitely you know the
drug drugs and everything that I've
chose to do and I've lost a lot of time
with my kids you know being in prison
which you know it I I hate it but at the
same time
I don't know if I would change anything
you know what I mean
because like
it's made me who I am like I am who I am
because of what I've gone through so
learn from your mistakes
what are you guys afraid of now what do
you worry about at this point in your
life
I'm afraid of
uh
I guess my my goal that I that I have is
to be the best dad to my kids that I can
be
and uh I haven't really started off too
great at that because I've missed so
much time with them
but uh I guess what I'm afraid of is
failing you know at being a dad
really that's about it
I
am afraid of
basically the same thing because
like me and my my kids dad's mom where
not on a green term so like
it's not gonna be easy to get my kids
back so it's gonna so I guess I'm I'm
afraid to not
be enough or be you know what is
suitable for the standards of me to get
them back would be
so I guess that would be considered
failure too
there's not much I'm scared of I try not
to be scared is it harder
being on the streets as a couple than it
would be if you're on your own
definitely not I feel like if we were on
our own we wouldn't it wouldn't it be
harder I couldn't make it without her
I'm telling you
this girl right here she she keeps me
going you know I want a strangle her
sometimes
but I'm gonna hang you off the roof one
day I love her you know
couldn't do it without her is it gonna
be harder for you guys to get cleaned if
you're together
no no the only reason I made it as long
as I did was because she was with me you
know if I was if I didn't have her there
to like you know keep reassuring me you
know you can do it you can make it and I
was by myself
otta said you know screw it and went and
got high on day two you know and it also
helped too because
we each have a different drug of choice
so
it wouldn't be a trigger to each other
you know what I'm saying right one's an
upper and one's a downer yeah how does
that affect your relationship
just when it goes when it takes so many
naps you know when you get high these
analytics pass out yeah you go to sleep
all the time that'd be annoying but it's
I got over it
and you're staying up all night yeah
yeah
we've learned to to work it out you know
what do you think of skid row you've
been here for how long yeah we ain't
been on Skid Row the whole time we've
been here we've only been out this way
for about what a week maybe a week yeah
yeah and I don't like it I'd rather go
out here that way I don't know this out
of MacArthur yeah we're out towards like
MacArthur Park that's not much better
and no but we were past it like you know
Pico and Hoover are my car
I'm gonna tell you that right now it's
like Zombieland that's what I call it
Zombieland after night you is a Zombie
Land play Zombieland
I went out there one night by myself and
uh it's like three o'clock in the
morning I told Scott I said listen I
don't care what the deal is don't ever
go out to that park or anywhere really
but especially the park by yourself at
night because it is
something else
he actually he actually fell asleep on a
park bench and got his phone taken well
that happens every every hour here right
and these fentanyl addicts are targets
for yeah and they took my phone right
out of my back pocket sitting at the bus
stop the fentanyl addicts you know them
because it you'll see them asleep on the
street with their pockets out like a
like a rabbit
yeah it's true
um it's true
like rabbit ears rabbit ears
there it is
you have friends do you have anybody you
guys trust not exactly yeah I just trust
him we don't really have nobody here
back home we didn't really talk to many
people either I have people that I've
met like in the program and like you
know I have a few people I've met you
know on the street that are they're
pretty interesting too you know I've met
some I have met some really really cool
people since I've been here though I've
met some crazy people but I've met some
people that you should tell them about
the the guy the the security at the
motel story I met this guy he's a
security guard and he was in the Marines
but he you know
he has a story yeah it's a nice story
you know I just met people that they'll
tell they'll tell us their their life
story and it's like and it makes me
almost cry you know it's like so
touching and like powerful yeah a lot of
people have been through a lot yeah this
guy got shot three times it's you know I
mean lived I'm I'm super glad that me
and her came out to California
but we've learned a lot I'm honestly you
know I'm I'm ready to go back
you know it's definitely it ain't like
the the pictures make it seem you know
it's not at all yeah you're not in
Kansas anymore yeah it's definitely and
there I haven't seen No Angels City of
Angels Los Angeles in there where's
Angels not these neighborhoods
but I'm I'm still I'm glad that we you
know it's definitely beautiful like some
parts of it are some parts and uh it's
not covered it's been a it's definitely
been an experience for both of us so I'm
glad that we came
uh we we did go to Venice Beach it was
nice there I liked it out there but I
the neighborhoods were nice and I think
we were planning to go to the Santa
Monica next Maybe
it was like up there there's so many
places that I want to go but we're on
foot so it's hard yeah it's hard to go
everywhere you want to go Hollywood was
nice to see the stars
yeah Hollywood was fun it was I like
Hollywood
what would you guys say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
lives
most important lesson
is uh I would say
um that's a good question don't I don't
know don't trust uh
the only person you can trust is
yourself really that's a that's the
that's the important lesson I've learned
because my whole life
I don't know it's just everyone that I
let get close to me I feel is
you know
had secret agendas
even back in North Carolina oh yeah yeah
are people any different there than they
are here
they're different but at the end of the
day and they're really all the same yeah
yeah everybody most I won't say
everybody because like I said I met some
really good solid genuine people but for
the most part everyone was like you know
just out for themselves
they could care less what happens to you
at the end of the day and uh I've come
to find that
she's the only one who is
meant anything that she has said and
stuck with she got on a plane and flew
across the United States with me
like and before this we were in the
woods in a tent you know I mean like we
were just like nothing and then I'm like
you want to go to California and she's
like yeah that's because he was
remodeling his dad his Grandpa's
property so we kind of it was kind of
abandoned and condemned couldn't stay
for her to take that just like yeah sure
and like go with me and trust me that
everybody would be okay
you know it's cool
excellent
all right Cayman and sky thank you so
much for sharing your stories yeah thank
you guys lots of luck you're not getting
away from here I know
all right thank you thank you